Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our
Fifth episode!
Already fifth.
Can you believe it?
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
FUWAMOCO MORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
Are you awake?
BAU BAU!
Well, let's go right to things.
There's important news!
There's been a Pero Sighting!
De-den!
You remember how we said we haven't seen him for a little while?
Right!
A Ruffian spotted him!
He has reported that he was seen in the Yellowstone National Park.
Yellowstone National Park.
This is America, right?
America.
Why is he in America?
That's a good question.
Do you have any ideas, Ruffians?
Why would he want to be here?
And look!
He's taking a bath.
That's good.
He can probably use a bath if he went all the way to America.
I have a feeling though that's not what you're supposed to do there.
Safety is important.
Right?
People might get mad though, you know?
It's not a good influence to others.
If you just wanted to take a nice outdoor soak, you should visit a proper onsen in Japan, right?
Maybe this isn't the place.
Maybe he just wanted it a bit hotter, right?
It's not an onsen!
He's chilling!
He looks kind of warm.
Maybe he just wanted a very intense soak.
Down to the bones.
To the bones?
Wait, that's a good question.
Does Pero have bones?
We haven't checked.
Well, Ruffians, I don't know if we would head to Yellowstone National Park if we'd be able to reach Pero in time.
So let us know where you see him next, okay?
Let us know if you have any Pero Sightings, okay?
Use the hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
Let's keep an eye on him.
This is gonna be a bit of a chase, I think.
BAU BAU!
Straight into things.
We had to go straight into things again today.
There's been a misunderstanding.
But we never have misunderstandings.
No.
I don't know.
While doing our first collab, Overcooked 2 with Biboo, there was a misunderstanding over Bijou's wonderful, hand-made, love-filled brownies that she gave us.
In our debut, we mentioned that we don't really like chocolate.
She found out.
But!
There's an important rule that we want you to understand, okay?
You need to understand, okay?
It's important.
We mentioned it, but I don't think some Ruffians would notice.
It didn't get to you.
That's why it's a misunderstanding.
You know, if...
Somebody that you love, somebody that's very important to you, no matter what, no matter if it's something you really dislike, you're like, I can't eat this.
It'll be delicious!
Because you know, they made it just for you.
Yeah, it's filled with salt.
Right!
So, Ruffians, you know, this goes for you too.
Because, you know, even if your mom, if she makes dinner for you and it's filled with maybe vegetables that you just really don't like,
And if you really want to, you could just take them out.
That's true.
But you know, and that's why Biboo's brownie was so yummy!
It was the best.
It was filled with love, so it was okay.
You know, also, I guess there were some Ruffians that were worried about if we were okay after eating it because of the chocolate.
Yeah, but... Are you forgetting something though, Ruffians?
I think so.
You know, we're not just some silly dogs.
No.
We're demon dogs.
Demon dogs.
Demon dogs, okay?
Chocolate's not gonna hurt us.
No.
It just doesn't taste very good, okay?
Yeah.
But regular dogs are different, okay?
So please make sure they don't eat any chocolate.
Yeah.
Safety.
No matter how much love that you maybe put into making it, I think maybe if you're gonna make chocolate, maybe make it for somebody else, or make it for yourself.
Yeah.
Yourself.
You know?
Can you make chocolate?
It's like a new chocolate.
From chocolate.
A chocolate from chocolate.
Yeah.
You just put more love into it.
Yeah, you know.
That's the important ingredient.
But yes, please make sure that you don't give dogs any chocolate.
Make sure you give them a healthy balanced diet instead.
Good food, okay?
That's important.
Very important.
Demon dogs are different.
Yeah, we're different, okay?
Understood?
We're not just a dog.
We're demon dogs.
Demon dogs.
BAU BAU.
And that's it!
No... This time we have a misunderstanding, but it's a bit different.
It's a bit more of a happy misunderstanding.
Happy misunderstanding!
Is this a sting?
I think so, this time.
It's a different misunderstanding, you know?
After our Rock'n'Roll Party last week, I think there was a bit of an influx of Ruffians comparing Moco-chan's voice, in particular Senchou-senpais.
The Marine-senpais.
But!
Well, that's really a great, great, great, great compliment to us.
I think Senchou-senpai herself, she said that she thinks differently.
And Moco-chan's voice is similar to... Is it okay to say?
Moco-chan's voice is similar to the legendary seiyuu Tange Sakura-san!
I don't know.
I don't know!
I couldn't believe my ears when I heard that.
I don't think it's true.
Do you think so, Ruffians?
Do you know who Tange Sakura is?
You know, right?
You know.
Nice.
Right.
You know.
We don't know Tange Sakura.
She's the OG cute voice seiyuu behind characters like Kinomoto Sakura from Cardcaptor Sakura.
Oh, right.
You know her, right?
Right.
That sounds similar.
One second!
Ruffians, we're back!
We're sorry there were some technical issues with the broadcast today, but we fixed the signals.
It's all good now.
Thank you for waiting for us!
Thank you!
Where were we?
Kage Sakura-chan!
That's right.
Okay, Ruffians, you know who she is, right?
Kinomoto Sakura.
You know, right?
Right!
Of course, of course, right!
Yes, she is the OG legendary seiyuu.
But, I don't know, do you really think that someone like Moco-chan can be compared to her?
I don't know.
Moco-chan, you are cute, but... Am I?
Maybe Moco-chan, can you do like an impression?
Impression!
Sakura impression!
Ruffians, would you like that?
Yes!
Okay.
Do your best.
I don't think it's gonna be.
It doesn't sound like it.
Weee!
It didn't sound like you.
No, not even close.
No, I'm sorry, yeah.
No.
I tried.
Ah, but thank you!
Thank you so much Senchou-senpai for the amazing compliment that makes Moco-chan very happy, right?
Right?
Yeah.
Thank you!
Thank you for doing it!
Well, next...
There's something I have to confess about.
Confession.
The other day, you know, in the final part of the Typing of the Dead, there was one moment, you know, where Fuwawa let out a very big scream.
In particular, a very blood-curdling scream.
Did you notice it, Ruffians?
Well...
You know, as Fuwawa, you know, I'm actually very, very scared of fire.
You know, I'm the fluffy one, right?
So, it makes sense.
Maybe...
I'm a little bit more flammable than Moco-chan.
You're just fuzzy.
Yeah, I'm just fuzzy.
But yeah, that's why I was really scared when we went into the scary incinerator and then there's the fire.
I have nightmares like that, you know?
So when I noticed that the door closed and that we were locked in...
Please scream more!
But yes, Ruffians, please be extra extra careful with fire.
You know, it's warm, and it's bright.
Yeah, warm things are good.
It's also very destructive, too.
Yeah, you have to be careful.
Actually, Moco-chan, you know, in Rebellion, you sing the Fire Fire Light the Fire.
Even that makes me a bit concerned when you say that.
No fire, please!
Only, I guess,
Yeah, water.
Be prepared just in case, you know.
Safety.
If I see one, I go into protect mode, so I've actually put out a lot of fires in my time.
But Ruffians, they weren't Moco-chan's fault.
Ruffians, don't give me any reasons to put out more fires, okay?
No more fires.
I haven't put any fires.
I'm not spicy.
Usually it just happens.
It's just kind of scary in itself, right?
Be careful with fire, okay?
It's serious.
Got it?
Serious, serious, serious.
Well, we thought, you know, we've heard a lot of different opinions and questions.
We've spent over a week with you now.
Almost two weeks.
But we're still hearing a lot of questions.
What is BAU BAU?
Ruffians, do you know?
Do you understand yet?
What do you think you know?
I want to hear the Ruffians' opinion first.
What is BAU BAU?
What is BAU BAU to you?
Do you have the answers?
Do you know?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU is life.
BAU BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
Not BORK BORK.
No, that's a different dialect.
I know we've heard a lot of voices from Ruffians being like, oh well, BAU BAU means stink in Indonesia, I think.
I think Malay too.
But, BAU BAU is BAU BAU.
Just BAU BAU.
BAU BAU is how Demon Dogs talk.
BAU BAU.
It's kind of hard for us to get rid of the habit of saying BAU BAU.
Does it bug you?
Do you think we should stop?
Should we stop?
BAU BAU!
No!
I'm glad!
It's good, it's good.
But yes, BAU BAU means BAU BAU!
Yeah, BAU BAU.
You know BAU BAU when you're excited?
Yeah, BAU BAU when you're scared?
BAU BAU when you're sad too?
BAU BAU all the time together with you!
Yeah, yeah.
BAU BAU.
It can mean lots of things, you know?
Like, good luck!
BAU BAU!
I love you!
Do your best!
BAU BAU!
We're rooting for you!
That's lots of different things, you know.
It's BAU BAU.
Hopefully, you know, maybe if BAU BAU is still a bit new to you, it will translate and you'll eventually be able to understand what we mean through our BAU BAUs.
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
Ruffians, do you think you have it?
I think I see some Ruffians that kind of understand, but maybe some Ruffians that are still getting the hang of BAU BAU.
That's okay.
It's a process.
Eventually, you'll be BAU BAUing just like us.
Yeah, it's just a process.
It'll be okay.
Yeah.
That's BAU BAU.
Also, this upcoming weekend is a very special weekend.
You know what it is, Ruffians?
I don't know what the Ruffians know.
It's Comiket 102!
Do you know what Comiket is?
Comiket is short for Comic Market.
It's the biggest doujinshi market event.
It's held twice a year in Japan.
It's held during summer and winter.
For fan comics.
It's really really fun, but it can also be quite an intense battle to get sought after books and merchandise before they sell out.
Yeah, it's not easy sometimes.
You know, if there's something you specifically want, you have to fight.
Fight, fight, yeah.
But we hope that you know any Ruffians heading out to the battlefield, that you're well prepared, especially for the heat, to know where you're going.
Please make sure that you get lots of food, lots of water, and to have a balanced breakfast before you leave the cave.
You need to power yourself.
Fuel.
Also, if you see any FUWAMOCO books, please let us know.
Okay!
You know, but it'd be really, really crazy to have something up so quickly.
You know, it's just our second week here with you, but we also want to get our paws on them too.
If you see any, make sure you BAU BAU at them for being really crazy, okay?
They're too crazy fast.
That's a crazy Ruffian.
But most importantly, make sure you pick one up too, okay?
Make sure you get one.
Good luck and happy NatsuComi!
Shall we head to our regular segment today, Moco-chan?
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
De-den!
It's Sissel!
Sissel!
She's a very particular, peculiar looking doggy.
Very cute though.
But very cute nonetheless, right?
Super duper cute even.
She kind of looks like, a bit delicious.
Delicious.
Especially delicious.
It's yummy smell.
You know, a beautiful grey lover.
Splashed with a bit of milk across the chest.
Very good.
Yum yum.
I wanna just put my face right in.
Right!
And there's some really cute side ruffles that look especially groveled on.
And we have some, you can't really quite see here, but we have the faintly, faintly pink cute little lips.
And the noise!
Very, very kissable lips.
Lots of kisses, lots of kisses.
Ruffians, maybe, what do you think this little BAU BAU is like?
What do you think?
Usually we think of it, but... Yeah.
BAU BAU.
Doggie of the Day.
Sissel.
Sissel's a Doggie of the Day today.
MOU MOU.
MOU BAU.
BAU MOU.
Oh, Sissel has an interesting... BAU BAU.
It's cute.
It definitely sort of awakens something.
Right?
You know, I think...
This is a doggy reading.
A very peculiar looking doggy, but very, very cute.
Delicious.
I feel kind of like something similar to when I see a cat.
I just need to... I need to do it.
But this is a dog, though, you know?
It's funny.
It's funny to feel that way.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
We went on a nice forest-y looking park jam maybe this time!
This is a pretty silly sight.
Their duty is your duty.
The dog doesn't really look too happy that someone's digging underneath them for treasure.
What treasure is there?
Excuse me, Doggy marks the spot.
He's just like, I'm sitting here.
Please, please don't.
Please don't.
There's no treasure here.
Excuse me.
Could you stop, please?
Yeah, let's give the dogs some peace though, you know?
But we're glad you enjoyed the watch!
BAU BAU!
Next, for our Question of the Day,
De-den!
Oh!
Today wasn't the greatest day for me, but your streams helped cheer me up.
We're glad that we helped.
So I'd like to ask, what do you two do when you're feeling down?
When you're feeling down.
This is a really good question too.
We understand, you know, sometimes, no matter what,
Just really can't help but feel a bit down.
Yeah, some days are like that, you know.
We have days like that too, but usually what we do is we think, okay, why am I feeling like this?
What's making me feel bad?
And then we sort of think about what we could do to make us feel better, you know, right?
Fix things.
Yeah, and sometimes it helps to talk to each other, you know, maybe Moco-chan's feeling a bit prickly and all we need is maybe a bit of an apology or to talk
Sometimes, you know, a hard reset is necessary, too.
You know, like, a nap to refresh everything, make you feel good again, you know?
Start things fresh.
But yes, you know, we always try to figure out what's making us feel off and do things better, you know?
But if you can't, that's okay, too.
Sometimes, you know, it's just out of your control.
It's a bad date, you know?
I think on those kind of days, maybe
You could just, you know, curl up with a good cup of tea and a blanket.
Maybe watch some anime that you really like.
Play a game.
You know, take a bath or go to bed early.
You know, those sort of things.
Just give yourself a bit more love and care.
Times are rough sometimes, but you know, you don't have to be rough everything.
Tomorrow's a new day.
Maybe it'll be a new FUWAMOCO Morning.
But maybe not!
That's okay.
Just take it every day, step by step, step by step.
It'll be okay!
Thank you!
We hope that today will be a really good day.
And you know what?
It's not only just a FUWAMOCO Morning.
Friday.
Oh, you're gonna go like that?
It's not just FUWAMOCO Morning today.
It's not just a Friday today.
We have another team.
Our next team is...
De-den!
It's our weekly Advent Club!
It's here.
And this time, we're playing Earth Defense Force 5.
Earth Defense Force 5.
We have two games we're playing that's 5 this week.
Oh, you're right!
And today's the fifth episode of FUWAMOCO 40!
It's... it's...
Ume.
Fate!
It's fate.
I thought you said it's Ume.
But yes, we're playing Earth Defense Force 5.
This is gonna be our first time playing it, but yes, we're excited.
It looks pretty silly, pretty fun too.
I don't really know what we're doing, but we're gonna protect everyone!
Yeah, protect humanity.
And, you know, Moco-chan and I, we've seen a little bit of Tokusatsu here and there.
Is it like that?
There's kaiju and stuff too, so...
You know, I'm excited.
I'm not too sure what to expect, but... You know, Admin will surely band together and will save all of humanity, so... Are we sure?
Is Shiori gonna protect humanity or destroy it?
That's a good question.
We don't know.
Never know with Shiori.
And that's why we love her.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, let's take another peek at our schedule.
Our schedule for the rest of the weekend.
De-den!
Moco-chan deshita deshita.
It says next stream at the bottom.
Next schedule, next stream.
We have another FUWAMOCO Rock Cover Party coming up!
This time we won't be singing old songs, new songs, old songs.
We're singing only hololive songs.
But to be honest, we're pretty nervous too.
I hope, Moco-chan, that you don't get too tongue-tied on some songs.
I'm gonna do my best.
It might happen though.
You don't believe in me.
Ah, no!
It'll be okay, right?
Right, Ruffian?
I'm gonna do my best.
You like Moco-chan when she's tongue-tied too, right?
You like me all the time?
Particularly this time though, I would like you to show your cool side.
Do your best, Tokei Moco-chan!
I'll try!
We'll also be appearing on Kiara-senpai's Holotalk interview that day.
Kiara-senpai said actually that this time it's going to be a bit different from usual, so we're really excited.
Please make sure that you don't miss it.
It's gonna be over at Kiara-senpai's channel.
It's not gonna be here, okay?
Not here, that doesn't make sense.
You have to go to Kiara-senpai's channel, okay?
And!
Also, we wanted to say a big thank you for all your votes for which language we should play for... Oh, which language we should play?
Dang, Sakura was 5 on Sunday.
I think with around 70?
70% of the votes?
At least the Japanese voice is wonderful!
But more importantly, we really wanted to say thank you to all the Ruffians for being so kind to each other.
All the Ruffians were so nice to each other, thinking about what all the Ruffians would want rather than maybe what.
That was kind of you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for making us proud!
Let's have lots of fun with Sakura Wars 5 on Sunday!
The start of a new journey, right?
Thank you so much!
I guess we're approaching the end of our fifth FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's gone by so fast.
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us again today.
There are many more FUWAMOCO Mornings to come, but before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU!